Ägyptens Lieblingsfrühstück heißt fool
Bohnenpaste Brot manchmal Eier dazu cool
ist praktisch es ist billig es stopft
den Magen bis zum Abend aber jetzt ist
wohl ein teures Frühstück und fühlen
sich die Kunden hier als ob man ihnen
den Teppich unter den Füßen wegzieht
jeder spürt es die Preise sind um 100
200 ja sogar 300% gestiegen also bei mir
war es so dass ich schlief aufwachte und
herausfand dass man Einkommen 50 65%
weniger geworden ist
Ägyptens Währung hat in einem Jahr die
Hälfte ihres Werks verloren die Stimmung
auf den Märkten zwischen Wut und
Ohnmacht schon vor dieser Krise stufte
die Weltbank 60% der Bevölkerung als arm
oder hilfsbedürftig ein
hier sind verzweifelt die da oben die um
unseren Präsidenten herum müssen doch
das Leid der Leute spüren dass Unrecht
das ihnen angetan wird wenn ich hier
sehe wie sie leiden werde ich depressiv
mittendrin
eine der wenigen die keine Angst hat
gefilmt zu werden wenn sie über ihren
Abstieg in die Armut spricht
jeden Tag ein anderer Preis
das ständige ausrechnen der Preise im
Kopf macht sie mürbe
Hühnchen des Fleisch der ärmeren ist für
shadiasemir mittlerweile ein Luxusgut
die Händler sitzen auf Ihrer Ware das
teure Tierfutter verdirbt das Geschäft
ich verstehe nicht warum die Preise so
krass gestiegen sind was ist die Ursache
dafür ich weiß nicht irgendwas stimmt
nicht mit diesem Land
wegen ihrer Gesundheit kann shadiasemie
nicht mehr regelmäßig als Friseurin
arbeiten das Insulin das ihr Ehemann
braucht ist 7 mal teurer geworden vor
kurzem erzählt sie habe die Regierung
den Bürgern empfohlen statt Hühnchen
Hühnerfüße zu essen so etwas höre sie
zum ersten Mal sagt sie verwundet
wissen Sie wir sind jetzt immer in Sorge
wenn der Strom oder wasserableser kommt
und wie die Rechnung bezahlen müssen die
Nachbarn fangen dann immer an
herumzuschreiben und zu streiten sie
sind gestresst ich mache das auch weil
ich auch gestresst bin und das macht
mich fertig
startet auf die Grundbedürfnisse seiner
Bürger einzugehen baute die Regierung
eine neue Hauptstadt viermal größer als
die Hauptstadt der USA 60 Milliarden
Dollar teuer mit dem höchsten Turm
Afrikas
und der größten Moschee Ägyptens
außerdem neue Straßen
neue Brücken
ein neuer Hauptbahnhof
eine Magnetbahn
eine luxusstadt am Mittelmeer
Schulden über Schulden nahm Präsident
abdelvatar escc dafür auf
just like das alles ist so etwas wie
weiße Elefanten sie sehen glanzvoll aus
man fühlt sich stark man hat den Best
aussehenden Elefanten der Welt und man
muss ihn füttern aber weiße Elefanten
sind nutzlos und produzieren nichts
die Mega-Projekte des Präsidenten
ernährten vor allem das
Wirtschaftsimperium der Armee
sagenkritiker jetzt sitzt Ägypten in der
Schuldenfalle als zweitgrößte Schuldner
des Internationalen Währungsfonds musste
es schon wieder um Kredite bitten aber
Kritik ist unerwünscht
ich ermahne die Medien
warum zeigt die Ägypter die Panik haben
etwas zum Essen zu finden
das ist falsch
als ob das Ende der Welt vor uns stimmt
ich möchte was schönes sagen weiß das
nicht schwitzt einfach nicht so viel
Unsinn
das Problem Ägyptens private Sektor
schrumpft seit Jahren mit dem Staat und
dem Militär kann er nicht konkurrieren
reham Fuder und ihr Mann investierten in
ägyptische Datteln und kämpfen jetzt
gegen die fieberhaft steigenden Preise
sie sind wie alle im Land auf Importe
angewiesen der Dollar wird jeden Tag
teurer Verpackungsmaterial kommt viel zu
spät an
letztes Jahr haben wir zum Fastenmonat
Ramadan eine große Menge Datteln
verkauft an einen Supermarkt den wir
kennen für dieses Jahr trafen wir die
gleiche Abmachung und plötzlich stieg er
aus dem Geschäft aus der Preis sei zu
hoch das gehe nicht er könne nicht
garantieren dass die Kunden dieses Jahr
genauso viele Datteln kaufen
2023 wird ein hartes Jahr sagen sie
die Krise jetzt Härte als vor 12 Jahren
damals als Ägypten für Freiheit würde
und Gerechtigkeit demonstrierte und
einen Präsidenten stürzte
viele revolutionäre sind heute im
Gefängnis
der Anwalt und Parlamentarier Seat el
alemi war eine der nach dreieinhalb
Jahren begnadigt wurde der
Sozialdemokrat landete im Gefängnis weil
er ein säkulares Oppositionsbündnis
gegründet hatte er gilt deswegen immer
noch als Terrorist
ohne einen Rechtsstaat ohne
Investitionssicherheit werde Ägypten
sich von dieser Krise nicht erholen sagt
er so vorsichtig wie möglich
Haram es ist schade Unternehmer aus
politischen Gründen festzunehmen wenn
sie es doch sind die an der Verbesserung
der Wirtschaftslage mitwirken sollten es
ist schade Denker und intellektuelle
festzunehmen denn sie entwickeln doch
das Land mit es ist schade Menschen
festzunehmen die ihr Land lieben und
ihnen vorzuwerfen das Land auf eine
falsche Weise zu lieben
[Musik]
nach Ägyptens Revolution hatte der
Präsident Stabilität versprochen aber
noch nie ist das Leben der Ägypter so
instabil gewesen
[Musik]